hey everyone eddie wu here it gives me
great pleasure to introduce you to my
friend
and mathematician poshen lo po
thank you so much for your time today
wow it's wonderful to see you again
it is a joy it seems like uh almost
another lifetime ago when you were
uh down here in sydney with me and i was
just uh such a delight to have you
uh in person but this is great as well
and i especially know
your time is very precious because uh
you're in between you know meetings with
people
internationally governments and their
ministries of health so
we're really thankful for your time but
i'm getting ahead of myself a little bit
but i introduced you as a mathematician
just now
and i'm a big fan of saying that you
know mathematics is about finding
patterns understanding relationships
so in a real sense everyone is a
mathematician
but i would classify you i guess as a
capital m
mathematician you're the professor of
mathematics at carnegie mellon
university in pittsburgh pennsylvania
how long have you been doing that for
oh i've been doing that for at this
point almost 11 years
wow okay you are truly part of the
furniture there that's excellent
we will get onto your kind of life as a
career academic a bit later and also
why on earth you would be talking to
international governments and their
ministries of health
but i feel like it's really important to
get to know you a bit better first
so i'm wondering if we could talk a bit
about your personal journey
into mathematics what are your early
memories of doing mathematics and and
your experience there
oh my so if i think about how math
started for me when i was in
elementary school primary school my mom
would teach us mathematics at home i was
the oldest kid
and we we spent quite a bit on
mathematics for only one reason it's
because they were from singapore
and they weren't exactly sure if they
were going to stay in the united states
and i remember my parents telling me
let's make sure that you learn what all
of your classmates in singapore are
learning
because if we go back to singapore that
way you won't be the bottom of the class
that was the sort of the motivation
that's delightful that you know
she was i i think it's amazing that as
you know there are lots of parents who
are going to be viewing right now
and the the huge formative influence
they have on their children
um positively and negatively um really
matters but i just love that it's kind
of like i don't want you to feel left
out
and you know that obviously the
singaporean education system is kind of
world famous
for how well um it really understands
mathematics and prioritizes that
so you know learning that at home i
think a lot of people
children going up might have had a
similar experience but but didn't come
out
enjoying mathematics the way that you
did can you tell us how that emerged
definitely because by the time i went to
middle school i i think at that point i
already had a very strong math
foundation that's thanks to my mom
but at the same time i didn't really
know what math was i knew how to compute
things
you know like if you think about what
people were learning back when i was
growing up which was the 80s
basically what you did is a lot of
computations you did a lot of
calculations with multiplication
division and so on
and when i got to middle school that's
when i discovered or rather
math competitions discovered me i was
going to a school in the united states
and there was an entire series of middle
school math competitions
where the principle was to give math
problems that you don't exactly know how
to solve
that is what got me really interested
that is so fascinating to me because
i feel like yeah a lot of people might
take the experience you just described
and actually you know that might be kind
of uh
you know someone's nightmare scenario
almost in terms like i don't know
what to do and then you know you give me
a challenge and i don't know
how to go about it but it's actually a
key it seems to me a key characteristic
of all the mathematicians i get to meet
and work with
that actually um the joy and the the
challenge of
encountering a problem that you've not
seen before and you think
i need to come with a novel way of
entering would that be a fair
description of your experience
definitely and i also think that that's
because maybe there's some personality i
actually don't like to do what i'm told
i'm one of these awful people that if
you say do things exactly this way i'll
say
but that would be boring you've already
told me what to do i want to put my own
spin on it but there's a reason i
phrased it this way
i think that's actually human nature i
think this is actually what makes
humanity keep finding new
ways to do things i'm not referring to
just mathematical ways i'm referring to
anything
we have a naturally i don't want to call
it rebellious but i want to call it with
a natural
nature to try to do things differently
than before and i think that's the heart
of experimentation
i just really enjoyed that in the
context where like on these math
problems
there wasn't any requirement that i do
well in fact because they were so hard
if you can't do them well they were
really hard anyway right so what's there
to lose
do your very best and see how far you
can get right now we will talk about
all those different competitions in a
second but before we sort of dive into
there
you know uh as i mentioned before you're
in university um as a mathematician
mathematics it forms bridges to so many
other areas and i think about a lot of
uh my friends who i went to school with
if they were gifted in mathematics often
they would go into
engineering or finance or perhaps
architecture
when did it solidify for you like how
old were you
when um it sort of became clear to you
that you wanted to go all in
with mathematics think that
for me when i was in grade school all
the way up until grade 12
i saw mathematics as something which was
a source of problems that you could
solve that could be quite hard
i didn't really know that it was
something i really wanted to think about
in fact i wouldn't have called it
beautiful back then i just call it an
interesting place to experiment
but when i went to university i had the
opportunity to learn from some really
passionate
professors and other instructors and
when you saw what made them interested
in the subject and how they could see
that
this fits together like some kind of an
interesting structure it's almost like
you're looking at something beautiful
under a microscope then you understand
why it's interesting
and then finally when i did a phd i was
very influenced by my phd advisor
a math professor named benjamin sudhikov
benny sudekov
and he also taught me what does it mean
to discover new things in math
if you can see i'm always naming people
for me people have been at the heart of
driving me to want to do various kinds
of things i think that's so fascinating
because
as i'm sure you've encountered many
times most people sort of a popular
conception
around mathematics it's it's a fairly
impersonal
and emotionless discipline but actually
the reality of it as you've just
described
it is it's in the context of
relationship and in fact you see someone
mortal to you
um you know their joy or delight or you
know perplexity and the fact that they
will
dive into the subject further because of
that now i think that's fantastic and
you were talking about competitions
before but
you weren't being very humble and you
just kind of said you know competitions
things you went into
but perhaps something that our viewers
need to know about you is that
in terms of competitions you have gone
right to the very tippy top
um there's something called the
international mathematic
mathematical olympiad that our viewers
might not be
familiar with could you tell us what is
the imo
sure i would say that the international
mathematical olympiad is
basically the olympics of mathematics in
the sense that it's a it's a whole
pyramid of competitions that in the
event
in the end you go and find who can come
up with interesting ways to solve
mathematical problems in new ways
from all around the world this is the
international part i say new ways
because
this is one of these competitions where
at the very end you have two days of
competition
each day has four and a half hours of
exam and
for those four and a half hours each day
you have three questions
so all together you have three plus
three which is six questions i can do
that kind of math so you've got six
questions to do
and if you can actually solve any one of
them you're a genius that's how this is
uh yeah so that's what i guess i got to
play around with those questions uh
when i when i was a kid also but i
should also say you know back when i did
this stuff it was a lot easier
if there are any people watching now who
are actually students doing these
competitions
now you have the internet now you can
watch eddie wu you can learn how to do
math
you know when i was doing this stuff you
didn't have all these resources so
maybe back in our day if you got some
qualifications there that doesn't mean
you're necessarily that good
sounds like there's been a bit of an
arms race between the competitors and
the people setting the questions
and now it sounds like the competitors
have access to so many more different uh
pieces of knowledge
it's very true to each sword isn't it
now it's really interesting to me i've
actually
um as a teacher um seen some of the
students
who i've taught um over the years and
i've kind of supervised them in kind of
the local versions
of the imo and you know sometimes i will
sneak a quick look
at one of the questions and like you
said there there's not many um it's
quite different to normals people's
experience of mathematics here's an
exercise
do a hundred questions um there's a real
emphasis on taking that time
depth of thought and creativity i
thought like you were saying before but
i'd really love to know
because um you are one of those rare
people who has who's entered in and also
performed at quite
high levels you're a silver medalist in
the imo
could you tell us about the atmosphere
and the people
is it hyper competitive or how would you
characterize it
actually it's quite interesting my
experience has been that the
higher you go in the competitions and
the more amazing the student is
the more humble they are i've actually
noticed
that i think somebody else said this
once it's like the more you know the
more you know that you
don't so so it's just that somehow
yeah the people who perform at the
absolute best at these are somehow some
of the nicest people in the world
who have seen that you know there's
nothing there's no point in acting like
you're better than anyone else and in
fact i see a lot of camaraderie in that
i actually feel like one reason why at
least in the u.s
the students are pushing so hard to try
to do these competitions is because they
make great friends there
and yes okay you'll have a fun like a
friendly challenge
somebody will win but in the end of the
day whoever won and whoever's number two
and whoever is whatever
they're actually all friends and i
suppose that would make sense because i
guess over the years
you would start to you know see these
people at the different competitions
over time
and also because this is shared love i
think that's very perceptive
and that humility that you mentioned is
actually really interesting because i
don't think we would normally
pick that out as a characteristic that
would say oh mathematicians
this is kind of what their personality
is like but it does remind me one of my
favorite metaphors is that
mathematics is a bit like mountaineering
you sort of climb these mountains
and i imagine you know going up to
whatever people are doing you know in in
here in australia might be
mathematics extension two it might be
specialist mathematics we might be
talking about ap
calculus but actually when you get to
the top of one such
mountain i i imagine from that vantage
point you just see
further mountains in the distance would
that be the way you describe it
absolutely and it's also like even if
you're just running up the pure
mathematics mountains at some point you
run up to the top and you say
wow there's all those other people over
there they're not doing math they're
doing things that are
like directly practically useful this is
also very interesting you know maybe
what we're doing is proving some theorem
maybe it could be useful someday and
there's some older people over there who
are making something that's practical
and you
there's this level of respect that you
have like if you've gone all the way up
a particular mountain you say
well it's that hard to get up this one
there's someone all the way up on that
other mountain over there
that looks really interesting i'm up
here
but how do you get over to that one i
guess you gotta go all the way back down
and go climb another one from scratch
and it is funny like we do say
mathematics um as if it's sort of this
this monolithic
object but actually like you point out
there are all of these different areas
and there is
diverse as you know different genres of
music or different
styles of literature or art right and
i'm going to come back to that idea in a
second
before we do that though i'm you know
talking about the imo you've
participated in it as a competitor
but now you're actually actually the
national coach for the united states
team
what's the difference between i mean
obviously there is a difference but i
picture
you know a coach for say a game of
football or tennis or things like that
um swimming i'm picturing someone you
know barking orders you know
from the side of the field and say you
know try this drill out and you know
work harder and there's a physicality to
it
what does coaching for the international
mathematical olympiad what does that
look like
for me because i used to be a competitor
the way that looks like for me
is i know how it feels to be sitting
there
how can i help you in the best way so
that you
make the most of yourself without
feeling a lot of stress
and i'll say because i remember being an
international math olympiad competitor
there's enough stress that comes from
yourself
it doesn't need to come from the coach
what comes from yourself is the moment
you know you're representing the entire
country
and whatever you do is going to be
mentioned like i don't know 20 years
later by somebody else interviewing
that's right someone could go and google
potion loan
imo results and they are still there for
all of time and posterity to enjoy it
yeah enjoy or not but what i mean is
like you already have enough stress that
you know that whatever you're doing is
actually at some national level
so my goal as a coach is just to to
hopefully help these people get as far
as they can and
i guess i always see in every one of the
students some example of what i used to
be thinking
i used to be feeling so i guess i see it
in a very empathetic way
and i've also noticed nowadays it's
quite interesting there's now an entire
generation of coaches who themselves
were contestants
and you can see that somehow a lot of us
are inspired
to coach not to win anything but to try
to help these people get as far as they
can
because we all see like people that we
used to be
is that um it's kind of paying it
forward isn't it you know you've had
this debt
of people coaching you and seeing the
way the places that's taken you
and it's fantastic to pass that gift on
i think it's delightful